Understanding a few things about how Unreal deals with content is important as this will
ensure that whatever content you're bringing into the engine will function in the way that
you want without any unforeseen performance issues.
And the first thing we're going to talk about in the content pipeline is the unit of measurement
Unreal uses when dealing with static or skeletal meshes.
Unit 5 uses centimeters for its unit of measurement.
So this means that one Unreal unit equals one centimeter.
It's best to make sure that your digital content creation tools such as 3max, Maya,
Blender, or whatever tools you happen to use have their system or scene scale set to centimeters.
This way you can avoid any and all scaling issues from your pipeline.
The next thing in our content pipeline I'd like to talk about deals with textures.
Now textures for the best performance should always be a power of 2 in either the X or
the Y axis.
This means that they can range from 2 by 16 to 128 by 256 all the way up to 4096 by 8192.
Textures do not have to be square so 64 by 64, 128 by 128 is good but you can also have
128 by 256 or 1024 by 2048.
Textures just need to maintain this power of 2 ratio in the X or the Y axis.
Unreal Engine also supports on import a number of uncompressed and compressed formats.
So for uncompressed on imports you can bring in BMP, TARGA, and PSD or you can bring in
PNG, JPG, DDS, and HDR depending again on what format meets the needs of your project.
When importing content into Unreal there's a couple of different ways we can do this.
You can either drag and drop right from the OS folder or your desktop right into the content
browser or you can click the add button in the content browser and then from there you
have a number of options under get content.
You can also click on the fab icon which will launch the fab browser inside of the editor
allowing you to search for and purchase content for your project.
You can even download content right from within the fab browser inside of the editor
for anything that you have in your library.